[Applaus]
Skiarena Ischgl vor wenigen Tagen hier
im Tiroler Paznauntal brummt das
Geschäft wieder als wäre nichts gewesen
die Schneeverhältnisse auf fast 3000
Metern Höhe sind perfekt
das lockt dicht gedrängt stehen
Menschenmassen vor der Talstation
Wartezeit 40 Minuten die Wintersportler
zwängen sich wieder ohne Abstand in die
engen Gondeln
[Musik]
ungetrübter Pistenspaß in strahlenden
Sonnenschein und dennoch so ganz wohl
ist nicht allen hier ein mulmiges Gefühl
bleibt auch fast drei Jahre nachdem
Ischgl zum weltweiten Corona Hotspot
wurde wir haben die Verantwortlichen
dazugelernt
dazugelernt ja es kommt immer darauf an
ob man dazu lernen möchte ne nein also
es ist alles so wie vor Corona keine
Kontrollen kein nix also wenn man sich
selber eine Maske trägt dann bekommt man
es hier gerade wieder also ich denke mal
das ist alles wieder wie vor also weder
irgendwelche Maßnahmen noch irgendwelche
Infos dass man irgendwas beachten soll
die Sicherheitshinweise einfach
durchgestrichen fertig und das trotz der
Empfehlung der Republik Österreich da
den engen Innenräumen weiter Maske zu
tragen
aber nicht nur auf der Piste auch beim
Après Ski tobt den Ischgl wieder der Bär
und werden Bilder aus zwei lokalen
zugespielt in der Disco schatziba heizen
Gogo Tänzerinnen die Stimmung an ab 16
Uhr bis tief in die Nacht ist es rappelt
voll und im kitzloch dort wo der Corona
infizierte Barkeeper im März 2020
mutmaßlich hunderte Touristen angesteckt
hat ist es wieder eng
ihm ist der Spaß an Ischgl längst
vergangen Maurermeister Jürgen Stang war
30 Jahre lang Stammgast hat den Ischgl
sogar seine Ehefrau kennengelernt er hat
sich in Ischgl mit Corona infiziert
landete nach seiner Rückkehr auf der
Intensivstation in der Uniklinik Köln
atmen weil sie kriegen keine Luft die
haben Angst einzuschlafen der Arzt sagt
sie haben ganz schlechte Sauerstoffwerte
wir können sie ins Koma setzen künstlich
ich bin fest davon überzeugt wenn der
Arzt mich in künstliche Koma gelegt
hätte dadurch die Sache nicht überlebt
hätte er leidet immer noch an den später
folgen spazieren gehen über kurze
Strecken ist das inzwischen wieder
möglich Stange hat Amtshaftungsklage
gegen die Republik Österreich wegen
behördenversagens eingereicht und
verlangt Schadensersatz denn als er mit
skifreunden vom Niederrhein am 7 märz in
Ischgl ankam war der Krone Ausbruch im
Dorf schon seit Tagen bekannt
verantwortungslos von den
Verantwortlichen man hätte einfach einen
Tal Anfang die lawinenschanke runter
machen müssen hätten gesagt pass mal auf
wir haben hier corona-fälle im Ort bitte
fahrt nach Hause wir können auf keinen
Fall in den Ort reinkommen aber man hat
wirklich aus Profitgier hat man die
Menschen ins Tal reingelassen peter
kolber ist Vorsitzender des
verbraucherschutzvereins VSV in Wien er
vertritt 3000 corona-opfer die 2020 in
der zweiten Märzwoche in Ischgl waren
der Verein unterstützt 100 Einzelklagen
auch eine Sammelklage für 150 Opfer wird
vorbereitet
es ist eine tragische Bilanz es sind in
Ischgl in der letzten Woche
wahrscheinlich 11.000 Personen infiziert
worden 32 Tote sind zu verzeichnen
unser Vorwurf an die Behörden ist dass
man Profitinteressen vor den Schutz der
Gesundheit gestellt hat schon aus diesen
E-Mails vom dritten und vierten März
2020 an zwei Hotels geht hervor in
Ischgl ist Corona bereits ausgebrochen
aus diesen E-Mails einer isländischen
Reiseleiterin mussten die Hoteliers die
das bekommen haben aber insbesondere die
Behörden wissen dass in Island 14
Personen positiv getestet worden die
eine Woche vorher in Ischgl waren und es
ist völlig unverständlich wieso die
Behörden da nach dem epidemiegesetz
nicht wirklich sofort gehandelt haben
wir hätten gemeint man hätte
Verkehrsbeschränkungen erlassen müssen
so dass die letzte Woche in Ischgl nicht
mehr hätte stattfinden können aber
niemand wird gewarnt nicht die Touristen
in Ischgl nicht die Urlauber die noch
anreisen im Gegenteil das Land Tirol
gibt zwar Pressemitteilungen heraus am 5
März 2020 wird behauptet isländische
Gäste im Tiroler Oberland dürften sich
bei Rückflug im Flugzeug mit Coronavirus
angesteckt haben und selbst nachdem der
Barkeeper aus dem kitzloch am 7 März
Corona positiv getestet wird
veröffentlicht das Land Tirol tags drauf
diese Pressemitteilung in der sogar
heißt eine Übertragung des Coronavirus
auf Gäste der Bar ist aus medizinischer
Sicht eher unwahrscheinlich
diese Presseaussendung war eine bewusste
ihre Führung der Öffentlichkeit die
Behörden wussten dass die isländischen
Touristen mit zwei verschiedenen
Flugzeugen zurückgeflogen sind die These
man habe sich im Flugzeug angesteckt war
unhaltbar
und in einer Zeit wo die WHO diese
Erkrankung zu einer hoch ansteckenden
Pandemie erklärt hat war das der Versuch
diese Infektionen in Ischgl zu
vertuschen das Oberlandesgericht Wien
urteilt im vergangenen Herbst über diese
Pressemitteilung des Landes Tirol Zitat
eine derart irreführende Information
wieder besseres Wissen muss als
rechtswidrig und schuldhaft weil
unvertretbar bezeichnet werden
das Gericht bejaht damit die
grundsätzliche Haftung der Behörden über
dieses amtsversagen wollen wir mit
iskels Bürgermeister Werner kurz
sprechen man gibt uns seine Handynummer
wir waren gerade hier im Amt wir machen
eine Berichterstattung über die
Situation drei Jahre nach der
corona-katastrophe ich bin nicht in der
Stadt ja ab wann sind sie wieder da so
gegen Abend aber da möchte ich nicht
mehr sprechen da bin ich müde
am Abend will der Bürgermeister nicht
mehr sprechen er ist zu müde auch Dörte
Sittich würde gerne mit jemandem aus der
Gemeinde Ischgl sprechen ihr
Lebensgefährte war ebenfalls Anfang März
2020 in Ischgl zum Skifahren 6 Wochen
später war Rudi lempik tot
wir haben viel telefoniert ich habe ihn
oft gebeten komm doch bitte wieder
zurück aber sagt Schatz hier ist alles
in Ordnung wir sind hier gut betreut und
hier ist gar nichts wir informieren uns
und hier passiert nichts naja wenn es
eine offizielle Warnung gegeben hätte
dann sind offizielle Schließung gegeben
hätte wäre natürlich gar keiner gefahren
das ist doch klar sie fahren doch auch
nicht in ein Katastrophengebiet wenn
alle sagen
bitte nicht hinfahren Rudi lampig musste
er sterben weil sie in Ischgl nicht auf
ihren wochenumsatz von rund 10 Millionen
Euro in der Hauptsaison verzichten
wollten
das zumindest glaubt antonell der alesio
wir treffen die Barkeeperin in Lech am
Arlberg wo drei Jahren arbeitete sie als
barschefin in einem Luxushotel in Ischgl
hinter der
für den wir gerufen
und er wird es gesagt dass wir nicht
sagen soll an die Gäste beruhigen soll
es ist nur ein Influenza aber das ist
kein Grund zu sorgen und wir wussten
dass es schon gravierende
Situation waren im Laufe und dass der
Gäste erkrankt war weil wir es selber
erfahren haben meine Mitarbeiter sind
ausgefallen eine nach den anderen die
würde nicht einmal getestet ihr Chef
hätte sich so behauptet sie vor allem um
die eigenen Einnahmen gesorgt ich war an
der Bar da läuft er vorbei es geht um
eine Millionen
und dann antworte ich hier ich gehe zu
mein Leben Chef nicht du mir das Geld es
geht um mein Leben auch sie infizierte
sich mit Corona und klagt auf
Schadensersatz doch vor Gericht erklären
die Hotelbesitzer die barschefin nicht
zu kennen frontal liegen zwei Fotos von
der Hotel Homepage vor dort eindeutig zu
identifizieren die barschefin in
hoteluniform wir versuchen vergebens mit
den Besitzern zu reden überhaupt wer in
Ischgl über den corona-ausbruch sprechen
will stürzt auf eine Mauer des
Schweigens und auch der Obmann des
Tourismusverbandes von Ischgl Alexander
von der Tannen bis unsere Anfragen
unbeantwortet
wir fahren in den Nachbarort See auch
ein Teil des schieferbundes Paznauntal
hier findet ein tourenski-wettbewerb
statt bergauf laufen auf Skiern und 100
Teilnehmer starten in die Nacht am Ziel
treffen wir den Bürgermeister des Ortes
der findet klare Worte zum damaligen
Versagen der Behörden
alles kann nicht richtig gewesen sein
sicherlich nicht man kann nicht alles zu
dem Zeitpunkt wurde sicherlich nicht
alles richtig eingeschätzt und sicher
sind Fehler auch passiert natürlich
trotzdem die Hotels die Gemeinde das
Land Tirol wie auch die Republik
Österreich sie alle bestreiten ein
Fehlverhalten in Ischgl wollen sie
Corona wohl vergessen nur vor Gericht
hat das Drama noch ein Nachspiel dort
Sittich will auf keinen Fall aufgeben
ich gehe so lange bis das Land
Österreich die Entschuldigung ausspricht
um auch da versuchen zu für
Gerechtigkeit zu sorgen oder
zumindestens zu gucken dass das
irgendwie nicht in Vergessenheit gerät
und das irgendwie Menschen nicht einfach
nur so sterben weil irgendwelche
Geldgier im Förderung steht
Ischgl der Name stand lange für Ski und
Party pur an die Corona Toten erinnert
hier nichts der Ort aber hat seine
Unschuld verloren